oh I am so happy smile Doctor Who series
10 episode - this is getting out a
little later than I like it I like to
try and get these out at least the
following morning from when the episode
airs if not the same night um I had a
busy weekend and I'm gonna give me a
heads up now I got a busy weekend next
weekend I got a busy weekend the weekend
after that so the next few of these are
gonna be a little bit later than I would
normally like them to be so deal with
that moving on so this episode this is
our follow up this is our chance to get
a sense of Bill actually you know going
on a more standard adventure now that
she has you know met the doctor been in
the TARDIS wrap your head around what's
going on what do I think it's okay I
mean that's just kind of where it lands
overall it's not great it's not terrible
obviously they're still kind of building
up the vault and I kind of wish that
have been a little bit more background I
don't think they had to bring it up
again right off the bat as hard as they
did I don't like how nardole fit into
this where we're right now he's you know
the doctor calls him mum he's the
nagging matronly figure who's trying to
stop the doctor from going out having
fun I don't I don't like that I think
that's a poor use for that character so
I figure somebody's got to change it
he's got to start coming on adventures
with them I don't know what that change
will be but so for right now that that
strikes me is a severe under utilization
of that character that said I can get
wine are doles not necessarily in this
one cuz this this is the episode that is
gonna give us the strongest sense of
sort of nailing down what that end
dynamic of bill and the doctor is and
two of them work pretty well together
I like that bill you know she thinks she
uses her brain but obviously she's not
as quick as the doctor is on her on his
own but she she does okay she's not dumb
the doctor himself is pretty good in
this he gets I kind of like that he he's
so certain
got to figure it out early on he kind of
gets carried away you know with oh I'll
just blow this up and I'll be fine and
and they and that might have been
something that would have caught my
attention like is that a good idea
except they've sort of wrapped it in
this idea of focusing on Bill and her
trying to get an understanding of you
know that he's not just gonna run away
and he is gonna try and stop and try and
prevent this dangerous situation from
killing more innocent people so that led
to you her having a better understanding
so they kind of hid his rashness in that
I thought that works pretty well as far
as the setting the situation they get in
it's pretty generic I mean it's not an
uncommon you know sigh futurist sci-fi
trope where you basically got machines
that kind of either misinterpret their
instructions or take them step too far
and end up being a detriment rather than
a benefit that's that's a pretty
well-worn trope as far as seeing it
realized here it's okay it's fine
there's a couple of clever things
involved in it I actually think the the
badges the emotional badges are actually
really well executed as a concept
because that sort of thing you know be
forced to wear an emotional bag so that
the the robots can clearly read that
again that that has an air of a lot of
sort of dystopian setting things where
you know you can't hide and you have
this thing that makes it very clear you
know what you know sort of broadcasts
you to the world and forces you to be an
open book but I like that they that they
took something that was not the most
original in in a way but found like
interesting little spins little ways to
tweak it like the fact that the person
is wearing it can't see it that's
actually yeah because otherwise you get
that emotional feedback we've been like
yeah no he's right that's a clever
little adjustment a clever a little
tweaking fact that it's on their back
and they can't look at it so you know
not an exceptionally original idea but
you know they didn't just do it they put
some thought into it it
kind of the same thing with the little
tiny machines the god I can't even
remember what they call them the VAR DS
they call them that the nanobots that's
the you know nanobots micro machines
whatever you want whatever you want to
call them again not nothing
exceptionally new there you know the
idea of the whole buildings being built
out of them was I'm not sure if I've
seen that exact thing done but it's
close enough to stuff that I have done
that it wasn't like oh kind of moment
but again the the episode was largely
about you know nailing down the dynamic
between the doctor bill I think it did
that pretty well but this isn't it's not
an episode that that bears revisiting or
ro done you know requires it nothing
about it made me go oh let me watch that
again right away
so it's but you know nothing nothing
about it made me angry nothing about it
was bad it was just fine it felt
it's not even filler it just feels like
this is this is kind of a process we got
to get it out of the way we chose a kind
of generic story in which to do it let's
move on let's see what comes next so the
ending capper felt I don't know kind of
tacked on and so I mean overall this
episode it's fine it that's obviously a
step down from the previous episode I
liked the pilot a lot so it is a step
down but it's not it's not a nosedive
and it's it's a step down in a way that
I understand why it's a step down
because knowing what the episode was
trying to accomplish in terms of
establishing character dynamics and you
know whether or not you want a more
involved story when you're trying to do
that so I get all that I get why it is
the way it is but it but it is still a
step down it's just not a nosedive but I
really would like the next episode to to
have a more clever story because the
pilot had a pretty basic story is well
kind of for a similar reason the point
was to establish Bill
to establish how she got caught up in
this world mean you don't need to be
telling you a complicated story on top
of that it can really can get wires
crossed that way so in both cases I
understand why the episodes are the way
they are can we get a more clever more
intricate more twisty or timey wimey or
unexpected story with the next one
because I feel like we've earned it at
this point so I guess that's that's
where I land on this one it was fine
what's next so that's it for smile it's
my thoughts on that one have you said I
hope you've seen it I'm not doing
spoiler free anymore cuz I've ruined it
for you if you haven't seen it but smile
second episode of Doctor Who series 10
what were your thoughts on whatever they
are drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter a
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Applause]